et oui nous nous sommes avec aimé
jacquet et mais on vient de vous voir
sur les champs elysées est-ce que ça a
été la plus belle ou la plus longue
journée de votre vie ça c'est la plus
belle c'est plus la plus forte parce que
tous ces gens qui viennent vous
remercier qui sont chaleureux heureux
qu'ils échangent un clin d'oeil ou un
petit signe de la main
c'est parfois je dirais réconfortant et
ça nous ça nous ça nous touche
profondément
on les voit tout cela derrière vous vous
allez rester amis c'est le terme jusqu'à
jusqu'à demain de votre vie mais je ne
sais pas si c'est le terme et on a
tellement de complicité on a tellement
de temps passé ensemble on a tellement
échanger on a tellement travaillé on a
tellement souffert on a tellement été
ensemble que cette page que nous venons
de tourner restera à jamais gravé dans
nos mémoires et on n'oublie jamais
personne al'inverse l'équipe brésilienne
on la disait miné de l'intérieur par des
clans et c est ce que quoique ça ça
pousse a pu faire la différence dans ce
match
moi je n'ai pas senti qu'elle était miné
c'est une équipe qui qui a peut-être pas
pu jouer son beau son meilleur football
qui a peut-être pas pu dans ce match de
finale parce que a été redoutable dans
le match
c'est un final peut-être qu'elle ne
s'attendait pas une équipe de france aux
ti aussi présente aussi sérieux et aussi
performante
je crois que là-dessus nous avons
peut-être réalisé une des plus belles
prestations de notre football fa chaque
fois vous nous avez surpris sur les sept
match toutes manières de france
la qualité et puis comme je vous l'avais
dit annoncé ans j'ai utilisé tous les
moyens et tous les toutes les forces de
cette équipe de france je sais que votre
rêve c'est d'emmener la coupe à sail
sous couzan votre village natal est-ce
que vous allez le faire et quand où et
on le fera mais un peu plus tard parce
qu'il est en ce moment j'ai beaucoup de
travail
chose promise chose due une dernière
chose vendredi on connaîtra le nom de
votre successeur à la tête de l'équipe
de france je peux vous demander qui vous
souhaiteriez voir parce que vous
répondriez pas mais vous qu'est ce que
vous allez faire maintenant à moi je
vais retourner à la direction nationale
à disposition du football de masse et
retrouver mon poste d'entraîneur
national
bon on prendra plaisir à vous revoir et
merci pour tous ces beaux moments de
bonheur que vous nous avez apporté tout
au long de cette coutume merci merci à
vous
[Musique]